plus grande est la certitude plus
grandes seront nos options de décider
face aux doutes on peut parvenir à
maîtriser ses peurs à se saisir de la
liberté ainsi offerte pour y déceler les
opportunités la certitude est un
formidable moteur
c'est ainsi que s'exprime le
pierre-marie les beaux chercheur en
neurosciences à l'institut pasteur et au
cnrs et je l'espère voilà des pensées
qui éclaireront nos échanges de cet
après midi aussi monsieur le ministre
dans le contexte très grande incertitude
que vivent les français et plus encore
les acteurs économiques il est je crois
essentiel de vous entendre sur les
orientations économiques de la politique
du gouvernement
pas seulement d'un point de vue
conjoncturel naturellement pour faire
face à la crise de la colline mais
également d'un point de vue beaucoup
plus structurels pas seulement sur
l'actualité immédiate sur le confinement
ou son absence mais sur le long terme
vous conviendrez sûrement que pour que
des opportunités deviennent des réalités
il faut probablement réformer notre pays
le rendre plus agile plus flexible plus
audacieux dirais-je aussi parfois
et j'entends par là lui donner une
capacité à investir dans des innovations
de rupture
pas en terme de recherche en termes de
recherche bien sûr mais pas seulement
également en termes de déploiement
quelles sont par conséquent les réformes
de structure que vous jugez encore utile
non seulement par des permettez-moi de
pardonnez moi l'expression pour limiter
la casse mais surtout pour relancer
l'économie française et améliorer ses
performances
quand cette crise sera derrière nous
voici le thème central de cette audition
alors bien sûr nous traiterons de
l'actualité si vous le souhaitez
confinement pas confinement etc mais
vous l'avez compris je souhaiterais vous
entendre avant tout sur la préparation
de l'après crise qui nous laissera
vraisemblablement un million ou plus de
chômeurs des bouleversements structurels
majeurs de notre économie est une
compétition internationale de plus en
plus féroce en termes de méthode pour
vous organiser des échanges de la
manière suivante je vais débuter par
vous interroger sur la politique
économique générale quelques grands
dossiers industriels
puis les membres de la commission vous
interromps seront à leur tour dans une
formule un peu différente de d'habitude
c'est à dire plutôt questions réponses
directes avec des interventions brèves
auquel je vous invite monsieur le
ministre à répondre également de manière
brève afin que chacun puisse exprimer
dans le temps imparti éviter les
frustrations d'audition précédente
j'invite mes collègues au nom d'une
forme de solidarité entre nous à
intervenir pour deux minutes vraiment
maximum et à ne pas reposer des
questions qui auraient déjà été posée
avant eux
premier sujet monsieur le ministre à
relance l'évolution de la pandémie de
lakovic 19 et la possibilité d'un
nouveau confinement font obstacle à la
reprise rapide que vous anticipez pied
il ya encore quelques mois et elle
invalide surtout les prévisions
économiques qui ont été faites pour le
budget à 2021 et le plan de relance
quelle conséquence vous en tirer
faut-il doubler la mise du plan de
relance comme l'a proposé xavier ragot
le président de la fcm qui souligne que
l'opération est désormais possible
puisque le coût du service de la dette
diminue faut-il croire olivier blanchard
auquel le président de la république a
confié un rapport attendu en mars sur
l'économie post co vide qui parle d'un
nouveau paradigme budgétaire est ce
qu'au fond il n'y a plus de limites
budgétaires et dans ce cas comment ne
pas répondre aux revendications souvent
justifiées des uns et des autres je
pense aux nombreux secteurs touchés par
la crise mais aussi aux différents
services publics qui ont été lourdement
sollicités ces derniers mois bien sûr
les services hospitaliers la police ou
aux différentes priorités pour l'avenir
de notre pays parmi lesquels les
nouvelles technologies la transition
énergétique le spatial et bien d'autres
ont résumé
jusqu'où va le quoi qu'il en coûte
deuxième sujet notre souveraineté
industrielle
je prendrai quelques exemples une des
premières leçons de la crise et la
nécessité de promouvoir l'innovation
française dans des secteurs vitaux pour
la nation or lorsque l'on voit les
difficultés de sanofi l'abandon du
principal projet de vaccin de pasteur
on a le sentiment que la france a du mal
à transformer le résultat de nos
recherches en développement industriel
quand on le fait comme dans le cas de la
société vale neva de loire-atlantique
issus de l'inra et finalement cela
profite peu à la france puisque deux ans
en 2021 les vaccins de cette société
bénéficieront exclusivement à la grande
bretagne
comment expliquez vous cette situation
plus généralement cela fait plusieurs
années que les entreprises de la biotech
nous alerte sur l'absence d'un marché de
capital-risque suffisant pour leur
développement
ma première question est celle ci est ce
que vous pensez avoir fait suffisamment
pour faire émerger un écosystème
favorable à ce type d'entreprises
innovantes qui se délocalise encore
aujourd'hui aux états unis pour trouver
des investisseurs investisseurs je pense
peut-être un moderna qu'on aurait bien
aimé garder en france sur un autre
domaine le gouvernement a annoncé la
semaine dernière l'abandon de la cession
des chantiers de l'atlantique à
fincantieri ce dont notre commission se
félicite le dossier est cependant loin
d'être clos selon la presse vous auriez
créer une cellule chargée d'étudier un
projet alternatif
comment cette cellule est elle composée
les élus des territoires les sous
traitants et sont ils associés en l'état
de vos réflexions quel avenir
envisagez-vous pour les chantiers
peut-on enfin envisager de mettre en
place ce que nous appelons de nos voeux
un capitalisme territoriales qui redonne
aux collectivités territoriales un rôle
plus important en matière économique
sur un autre sujet vous êtes opposé nous
vous avons entendu à ce sujet aux
questions d'actualité au rapprochement
entre carrefour et couche tard
entraînant l'abandon de ce qui était à
peine un projet vous aviez évoqué les
inquiétudes relatives à la sécurité
alimentaire considérée comme stratégique
pour la nation pourtant le canada est un
pays ami avec lequel l'union européenne
a récemment signé le ceta traité de
libre échange que vous soutenez
fermement la semaine dernière alstom a
finalisé le rachat du canadien
bombardier sur les rails depuis depuis
plus d'un an
mariage qui c'est réel
et sans obstacle votre intervention dans
ce dossier ne risque-t-elle pas d'avoir
des conséquences sur d'autres dossiers
des conséquences sur nos relations
économiques avec le canada et plus
généralement sur l'attractivité de notre
pays pour les investisseurs dans un
autre secteur non moins stratégique
celui de l'énergie le groupe angie
entend céder le contrôle de l'entreprise
française gtt mais je ne vous interresse
pas sur cette question car vous avez eu
la gentillesse de me répondre juste
avant cette audition
je voudrais évoquer également l'accord
de principe conclu ce mois-ci entre
l'union européenne et la chine en
matière d'investissement les arts
présente cet accord comme une
opportunité à saisir pour les européens
avec l'ouverture du marché chinois
les autres comme une porte grande
ouverte pour les acquisitions prédatrice
de nos amis les chinois nous entendons
qu'il est très bon pour l'allemagne et
pour son industrie automobile qu'en est
il pour nos entreprises notre territoire
aujourd'hui deux tiers des
investissements chinois en europe serait
le fait d'entreprises d'état cela ne
présentait pas de vrais risques en
matière de souveraineté
j'en profite pour vous pose également la
question du document de travail sur le
projet d'accord d'association entre
l'union européenne et le mercosur
quelle est la position du gouvernement
sur cet accord envisagez-vous vraiment
de pouvoir accepter un tel accord sans
le renégocier en profondeur sur tous ces
sujets je voudrais vous rappeler que la
loi pacte oblige le gouvernement à
remettre au parlement un rapport annuel
sur l'action du gouvernement en matière
de protection et de promotion des
intérêts économiques industriels et
scientifiques de la nation plus
particulièrement sur filtrage des
investissements étrangers c'est d'autant
plus important que depuis l'adoption de
cette loi le gouvernement n'a pas été
inactif il a abaissé le seuil de
contrôler les opérations et allergies le
champ des secteurs stratégiques
mais le parlement de la place en rapport
et ce malgré plusieurs rappels donc
peut-être aurez-vous la gentillesse de
nous indiquer quand est-ce que nous
pourront le recevoir même si nous
comprenons que l'actualité est chargée
enfin au niveau franco français je
voudrais dire quelques mots du
rapprochement entre veolia et suez qui
est entrée dans une nouvelle phase un
projet alternatif a été mis sur la table
par les frères hardy
l'egypte je voudrais savoir quel est le
rôle est l'objectif de l'état dans ce
dossier
après son volte face l'état vis-à-vis de
la cession des parts d' angie depuis sa
relative impuissance à faire naître une
discussion amicale l'état qu'elle est
qu'elle est calé par dont l'action de
l'état aujourd'hui
continuez-vous à pousser les deux
entreprises au dialogue
le cas échéant bpi france ou la caisse
des dépôts seraient ils prêts à
participer à un tour de table pour
soutenir le projet alternatif pour suez
voilà monsieur le ministre les premières
questions je voulais vous poser et je
vais bien sûr vous passez la parole pour
y répondre ou sur tous sujets que vous
jugerez utile
merci maintenant la présidente avant de
prendre un peu de temps mais je vous
propose de bouleverser un peu l'ordre
des choses pour respecter au rappel des
instructions mais recommandations et
règles du jeu puisque c'est où la
présidente est donc plutôt que de vous
faire un exposé liminaire répondre
directement aux questions de la
présidente serait juste une brève
introduction avant de répondre très
concrètement à toutes les questions
essentielles qui m'ont été posées
d'abord une première remarque pour vous
dire ma confiance profonde dans
l'économie française
je sais que les temps sont extrêmement
difficile pour les français
extrêmement difficile pour beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs qui sont aujourd'hui les
volets fermés qui ne peuvent pas exercer
leur activité pour des raisons de
sécurité sanitaires extrêmement
difficile pour des centaines de milliers
de salariés qui ont perdu leur emploi
même si nous avons amorti le choc mais
pour autant je le redis la france a une
capacité de rebond économique
exceptionnelle et je voudrais pas que
nous cédions par fatigue par lassitude à
un discours défaitiste que n'attendent
pas les français et qui ne correspondent
pas à la réalité de ce que les
entrepreneurs français les salariés
français essaye de faire tous les jours
sur vos territoires
nous avons des capacités de rebond
exceptionnel et nous avons montré au
troisième trimestre de 2020 plus de 18%
de croissance
nous l'avons montré en ayant une
récession moins importante que prévue en
2020 puis 3% au lieu des 11 % que nous
attendions pour l'année 2020
nous l'avons montré aussi avec un très
fort rebond de la consommation des
ménages
on descend donc nous confondons pas un
problème conjoncturel loup
difficile qui est celui de la pandémie
et les règles sanitaires qui vont avec
avec la réalité structurelle de
l'économie française l'économie
française a des fondamentaux qui sont
solides et que nous avons
considérablement améliorée en l'espace
de plus de trois ans en transformant la
fiscalité française en rendant le
territoire français le plus attractif de
tous les pays européens en améliorant la
compétitivité notre économie en recréant
pour la première fois de plus de 10 ans
des emplois industriels et en faisant
baisser massivement le chômage donc
ayons confiance l'économie française je
le redis à des capacités de rebond qui
sont très importantes
ça n'interdit pas de réfléchir comme
vous m'avez invité à des transformations
structurelles qui reste nécessaire
il est évident que nous devons encore
améliorer ce qui est fait en termes de
formation de qualification des salariés
beaucoup effet par elisabeth bornes mais
dans un moment de grande transition
technologique il est indispensable de
permettre aux salariés de changer plus
facilement d'emploi et d'acquérir plus
facilement une qualification
je reste convaincu que la somme globale
de travail de la nation française est
insuffisante par rapport à ses grands
partenaires développer et c'est pour moi
une conviction forte si nous ne voulons
pas l'appauvrissement notre pays nous
devons tous travailler collectivement
davantage et je ne dis pas en critiquant
l'un ou l'autre bien sûr que les
salariés français travaillent beaucoup
bien sûr que les salariés français ont
fait des efforts absolument considérable
mais vous pouvez tourner le problème
dans tous les sens
tant que nous aurons un niveau de
chômage aussi élevé des personnes qui
partent plutôt que dans d'autres pays à
la retraite et des jeunes qui entrent si
difficilement sur le marché du travail
réalité qui est encore plus cruelle
aujourd'hui nous risquons de ne pas
garantir aux générations qui viennent à
nos enfants et à nos petits-enfants
lemay
niveau de vie que celui que nous avons
et je pense qu une responsabilité forte
que nous avons c'est de garantir à nos
enfants et à nos petits enfants qu'ils
puissent avoir un niveau de vie meilleur
que le nôtre et c'est certainement pas
en mettant les problèmes structurels de
l'économie française sous le tapis que
nous leur rendons sa hausse voilà pour
la question des réformes de structure
vous voyez que je change assez peu de
conviction sur le sujet sur le plan de
relance certains ont proposé mavs
interrogé sur ce sujet de multiplier par
deux le plan de relance pardonnez moi de
trouver cette idée surprenante nous
avons et vous avez voté un plan de
relance et je vous remercie parce qu'il
a été voté très largement par les deux
assemblées il y a quelques semaines
il représente 100 milliards d'euros
la vraie difficulté aujourd'hui n'est
pas de rajouter des milliards fictifs il
est que l'argent arrive dans les
territoires dans les entreprises dans
les pme dans la formation des salariés
sur les jeunes pour qu'ils puissent être
embauchés sur les apprentis pour qu'il
puisse trouver une place et croyez moi
il est beaucoup plus difficile de
garantir la bonne exécution du plan de
relance que d'annoncer à grand renfort
de roulement de tambours et de sonneries
de trompettes qu'on va rajouter à
nouveau 20 30 40 ou 100 milliards et je
préfère toujours dans ma vie politique
la difficulté à la facilité oui il est
plus difficile de garantir la bonne
exécution du plan de relance que de
proclamer qu on va rajouter des dizaines
de milliards d'euros
et donc ma responsabilité aujourd'hui
c'est de faire en sorte que l'argent
soit décaissés pour qu'ils donnent des
résultats en termes d'emploi et en
termes de croissance économique pour nos
compatriotes je peux donner quelques
exemples et des politiques qui marchait
très bien
prenez la politique de digitalisation
des pme nous avions prévu 280 millions
d'euros
il se trouve que des milliers de pme ont
demandé à avoir accès à ce crédit
d'impôt pour la digitalisation et que
nous
on s'en doute 800 millions d'euros a
décaissé sur cette politique tant mieux
elle marche mais je préfère me
concentrer sur les crédits que nous
allons trouver qui sont nécessaires pour
que cette politique soit financé plutôt
qu'une nouvelle fois devoir rajouter de
nouveaux milliards qui risque fort
d'être des milliards fictifs deuxième
exemple les appels à la relocalisation
industrielle fonctionne aussi très bien
je pense aurait pu voir dans vos
territoires que certaines entreprises
dit là bas nous on n'a pas été
sélectionné c'est dommage on avait un
beau projet parce que effectivement j'ai
fait le point aujourd'hui avec les
préfets nous avons largement épuisé ses
enveloppes là il sera nécessaire de
réallouer des fonds une politique qui
marche moins bien vers ces politiques
qui rencontre un grand succès
la prime rénove rencontre aussi un grand
succès la prime à la conversion
rencontre un grand succès la prime pour
l'embauché des jeunes rencontrent un
grand succès la prime pour l'embauché
d'apprentis rencontre un grand succès à
tel point que nous avons eues en 2020
plus d'apprentis embauché en pleine
période de crise qu'en 2010 9 485 milles
très exactement
donc je le redis toutes les propositions
sont les bienvenues et les instituts
sont dans leur rôle de faire des
propositions mais ne cédons pas à la
facilité de rajouter des annonces de
dizaines de milliards d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires
quand en réalité le vrai défi est de
s'assurer que ces euro sont dépenser
intelligemment rapidement de manière
efficace pour nos compatriotes part bien
entendu cela nous amène à la question de
l'endettement que vous m'avez posée est
ce qu'aujourd'hui il est raisonnable de
sonde était la réponse est oui
il est raisonnable de s'endetter d'abord
parce que le coût de l'endettement est
faible je rappelle que en moyenne sur
les obligations du trésor à 10 ans nous
avons un taux d'intérêt négatif à -0
réguler 33 donc c'est la première raison
pour laquelle il est raisonnable de
s'endetter
c'est que le coup eli
ite pour les finances publiques la
deuxième raison c'est que nous avons
besoin d'investir et c'est tout le sens
des questions doit y est posée madame la
présidente
si notre politique devait se résumer en
un seul mot aujourd'hui c'est
l'investissement l'investissement et
l'investissement
or aujourd'hui les entreprises ne sont
pas nécessairement inciter à investir
l'environnement économique est trop
incertain ya trop d'inquiétude donc le
rôle la puissance publique aujourd'hui
est de soutenir l'investissement y
compris par de la dépense publique donc
cette nette si elle va à de
l'investissement et de la bonne dette
en revanche je ne suis pas favorable à
de l'endettement qui rêve à des dépenses
de fonctionnement pérennes autant c'est
le rôle de l'état de se substituer à de
la dépense privée quand les
investisseurs hésitent parce qu'ils se
disent mais est ce que c'est vraiment le
bon moment
autant c'est le rôle de l'état dé
soutenir l'investissement des
entreprises privées notamment en leur
donnant accès à des fonds propres en
particulier par les prêts participatifs
dont j'annoncerai le fonctionnement dans
les prochains jours parce que là nous
créons l'incitation à l'entreprise pour
qu'elle investisse qu'elles innovent
qu'elles mettent de l'argent dans la
recherche alors qu'elle ne le ferait
peut-être pas naturellement
c'est notre rôle autant retrait des
dépenses pérennes le fonctionnement qui
pèserait durablement sur les finances
publiques nous empêcherait de rétablir
les finances publiques
à terme et du coup dégraderait la
situation du pays c'est la ligne de
partage très clair que nous avons fixés
avec le président de la république et
avec le premier ministre
s'endetter pour investir oui s'endetter
pour la dépense de fonctionnement non ou
interrogé également sur l'indépendance
de notre pays en matière économique
je reviendrai sur les dossiers plus
précis sur lesquels vous m'avez
interrogées qui ont été sur le devant de
l'actualité
nous avons avec cette crise une
opportunité unique de nous interroger
sur les chaînes de valeurs françaises
et de nous apercevoir que effectivement
quand on regarde la manière la plus
objective possible notre situation
économique
ces chaînes de valeur souffre de deux
défauts
le premier c'est qu'elles ne sont pas
suffisamment nombreuses et que nous nous
sommes reposés depuis à peu près 30 ans
sur les mêmes chaînes de valeurs
excédentaires à l'exportation qui rit
tout notre territoire qui sont des
motifs de fierté mais qui nous expose
terriblement quel retournement de
conjoncture
ces chaînes de valeur ou les connaissez
c'est l'agroalimentaire c'est
l'aéronautique c'est le luxe c'est la
chimie
surtout ces secteurs-là nous sommes
effectivement excédentaire et
économiquement solides
le malheur c'est que quand il y à une
pandémie et les avions restent cloués au
sol et donc l'aéronautique se retrouve
en très grande difficulté que lorsque
vous avez donald trump au pouvoir qui
impose 25% de sanctions sur les
exportations de vins c'est toute la
filière agroalimentaire dans laquelle
les vins et spiritueux représentent une
part très importante qui se retrouve
fragilisée également que lorsqu'on avait
plus composants critiques notamment dans
le secteur médical tout le secteur de la
santé et de la chimie médical qui est
lié se retrouvent aussi fragilisé donc
il est indispensable de recréer des
nouvelles chaînes de valeur pour ne pas
nous reposer sur nos lauriers
nous avons fait ce travail depuis
maintenant près d'un an avec la
direction générale des entreprises avec
des chercheurs avec des économistes pour
essayer de définir de nouvelles chaînes
de valeur car le deuxième défaut que
nous avons c'est un problème
d'indépendance et de souveraineté
nous nous sommes aperçus à la faveur de
cette crise un que nous étions trop
exposés parce que nos richesses reposer
sur un nombre trop limité de filière est
en 2e mieux que nous et autres
dépendants de l'approvisionnement
extérieur quand on s'est aperçu que le
véhicule électrique décollé de manière
tout à fait stupéfiante et que les
achats progressait fortement mais qu'on
s'est aperçu dans le même temps
que le tiers de la valeur d'un véhicule
électrique c'est à dire la batterie
électrique venait à 85% de chine ou de
corée du sud
là vous touchez du doigt très
concrètement le problème stratégique que
vous avez votre valeur n'est plus créé
en france elle est importée donc quand
on dit relocalisation le terme est à mon
sens inapproprié le vrai terme c'est de
recréer des chaînes de valeur en france
c'est à dire de la production qui va
reposer sur du savoir-faire des
technologies de la formation dont va
dépendre la création de valeur et
d'emplois dans notre pays
le véhicule électrique et la batterie
électrique et alex en exemple si
l'industrie automobile français se
contente de faire la carrosserie et les
pneus mais ne fait pas les batteries
électriques
eh bien vous perdez toute la valeur
future de l'industrie automobile d'où la
décision que nous avons prise de créer
nos propres batteries électriques avec
l'alliance qui était créée par psa total
et saft avec l'ouverture d'une première
usine en 2022 dans le nord de la france
deuxième exemple l'hydrogène c'est très
bien de se dire qu'on aura en 2035
un avion décarbonée mais pour ça faut
des piles à hydrogène
il faut donc maîtriser la production
d'hydrogène en france c'est des
investissements qui se chiffrent en
milliards d'euros
nous avons décidé de faire de
l'hydrogène une des filières chaîne de
valeur critique dans notre pays ce
pourrait citer d'autres chaînes de
valeurs sur lesquelles je pense que nous
pouvons être leader dans les années qui
viennent
le cantique les télécommunications les
nanoélectronique et notamment les
composants électroniques de la
nanoélectronique
les biothérapies qui font partie de ces
chaînes de valeurs sur lesquelles la
france a des avantages comparatifs
considérable surtout cela nous avons
décidé dans le cadre du plan de relance
et du plan d'investissements d'avenir
d'investir pour le seul plan
d'investissements d'avenir 11 milliards
d'euros
dans les deux années qui viennent
j'ajoute deux points importants
ces chaînes de valeur le suppose qu'il y
ait derrière une véritable stratégie
industrielle de long terme les choix
n'ont pas été faits par le miz économie
et des finances est tout seul dans son
bureau
je le redis c'est venu du terrain des
entreprises des chefs d'entreprises des
chercheurs des économistes sur la base
de trois critères qui sont remplies dans
chacune de ces chaînes de valeur premier
critère il faut qu'il y ait un marché a
pas de développer des chaînes de valeur
sur des marchés qui n'existe pas sur
l'hydrogène pour prendre cet exemple là
on sait que pour les transports
collectifs pour l'avion pour les bus
pour les trains l'hydrogène est
effectivement une technologie porteuse
d'avenir sur lesquels il existe un
marché et une demande
deuxième critère il faut que la france
et des technologies et des
investissements dans ses technologies
qu'ils soient déjà en cours de
réalisation pour qu'on ne partait pas de
rien c'est le cas sur le cantique on est
une école de mathématiques
exceptionnelle des chercheurs du cnrs
exceptionnel va le plateau de saclay
nous avons visité que le présent la
république il ya quelques jours qui a
des atouts les avantages comparatifs
considérable il faut enfin qu'il y ait
des industriels qu'ils puissent
développer ses technologies et on l'a vu
dans le domaine médical et dans le
domaine des vaccins c'est bien ce qui
nous a manqué donc nous avons en matière
de développement industriel
quand vous regardez l'hydrogène je
reprends toujours cet exemple au moins
deux entreprises une très grande connu
tout le monde
air liquide une plus petite mais très
performantes et moins connues que
j'appelle mcphee qui fait que si on met
de l'argent qu'on fait de la recherche
le développement industriel ne se fera
pas à l'étranger mais bien en france
parce qu'on a déjà les briques
industriels et quand on regarde et leçon
qu'on peut tirer de l'expérience de
cette crise
qu'est ce qui manque à la france un lien
plus étroit entre recherche et
développement industriel et nous nous
sommes battus dans le cadre de la loi
pacte pour que ce lien soit plus étroit
et je ne vais cesser de le dire c'est
important de regarder des conflits
d'intérêts oui mais ses 13 enfants
aussi de vérifier qu'il ya vraiment un
lien étroit entre recherche et
développement industriel sinon on va
systématiquement se faire doubler par
les américains les chinois voire
d'autres pays européens il faut que nous
tous ici comment responsables politiques
nous nous interrogions sur les barrières
peut être excessive que nous avons mises
entre le monde de la recherche et le
développement industriel pour au
contraire permettent d'avoir plus de
fluidité entre le monde de la recherche
et le développement industriel derrière
deuxième chose avec elle il faut que
nous interrogions collectivement jean 30
août ma part tous ces développements
industriels demandent beaucoup de
financement beaucoup d'argent et le
ticket d'entrée pour une start up qui
veut se développer dans des domaines
aussi compétitif c'est pas le million
c'est pas le dizaines de millions que
c'est pas la centaine de millions
notamment dans le domaine médical c'est
le milliard d'euros donc il faut que
nous ayons en matière de capital risque
le financement de l'investissement
d'union des marchés de capitaux
beaucoup plus ambitieux si nous ne
mettons pas l'argent à disposition des
entreprises qui veulent grandir à cette
technologie d'avenir
nous nous ferons doubler une nouvelle
fois pas des géants adossés à des start
up qui se trouvent aux états unis et en
chine parce que nous n'aurons pas donné
les moyens à nos entreprises de se
développer suffisamment
enfin troisième point la stratégie qui
doit nous permettre de tirer les leçons
de ce qui s'est passé pendant cette
crise économique et sanitaire
il faut jouer collectif avec nos
partenaires européens
parce que les enjeux financiers sont
tels et les besoins de recherche sont
telles que c'est uniquement en
travaillant main dans la main notamment
avec nos partenaires allemands qu'on
peut espérer être à la taille critique
les deux autre continent que sont la
chine et les états unis jeu super ce
n'est que si on tire les trois leçons de
ces retards que nous avons pu prendre le
développement de certaines technologies
1 un lien plus étroit recherche
industrie de une capacité de financement
3 une capacité à travailler un européen
nous avons bon lieu d'espérer que nous
saurons au même niveau que les états
unis et la chine dans les décennies qui
viennent
sur les sentiers de l'atlantique je
voudrais juste revenir une seconde sur
l'historique de ces chantiers qui sont
un fleuron industriel français qui fait
notre fierté collectif en grande
difficulté économique les chantiers de
l'atlantique avaient été cédés en 2008 à
un acteur coréen stx
cet acteur coréen a fait faillite en
2016 un accord alors été signé lors du
précédent mandat pour une reprise de stx
par les italiens fincantieri avec un
partage à 54,46 en faveur de la partie
italienne en 2017 lors d'un déplacement
sur les chantiers de l'atlantique le
président de la république a indiqué
qu'il estimait que cette cession à 54,46
était déséquilibrée et il a demandé à
son ministre de l'économie et des
finances que vous avez riboud ce soir de
renégocier les modalités de cet accord
avec la partie italienne après plusieurs
semaines de négociations nous sommes
arrivés le 27 septembre 2010 est un
accord prévoyant que les chantiers de
l'atlantique sera partagé à 50/50 entre
l'italie et la france + 1 % traités par
l'état français sur une durée de 12 ans
à la partie italienne
et si au bout de 12 ans l'ensemble des
conditions de jeu ont fixé la partie
italienne étaient remplies dans ce cas
là et dans ce cas là seulement la partie
italienne pouvait prendre la majorité
dans les chantiers de l'atlantique entre
2017 et maintenant inutile de vous dire
que la situation a profondément évolué
elle a profondément évolué parce que le
tourisme a été touché de plein fouet par
la crise sanitaire et les croisiéristes
par la même occasion
dans ces conditions là il nous a semblé
en france comme en italie
et du côté de la commission européenne
également que l'opération perdait de sa
pertinence
nous avons donc décidé il ya quelques
jours d'abandonner au regard des
nouvelles
dition de marché est la situation de
marché de la croisière et du tourisme
d'abandonner le projet de fusion entre
fincantieri et les chantiers de
l'atlantique
maintenant il faut trouver un partenaire
pour les chantiers de l'atlantique qui
désormais sont détenues à plus de 80%
par l'état français
je le redis j'ai reçu l'ensemble des
acteurs locaux
nous agirons en toute transparence avec
eux nous voulons trouver des partenaires
économiques et industrielles pour les
chantiers de l'atlantique
nous le ferons en coordination étroite
avec les élus locaux et nous le ferons
sans précipitation partir du moment le
chantier de l'atlantique sont détenu à
80% par l'état s'il y a une option
crédible nous prendrons cette option
mais nous voulons étudier ses options en
transparence totale avec les élus locaux
que cela fasse l'objet d'un accord de la
part des élus locaux et nous le ferons
sans précipitation s'agissant du
mercosur
je sens totalement de sujet mais je suis
l'ordre des questions se rappelle que
nous estimons que les conditions ne sont
pas remplies pour une signature de cet
accord du mercosur notamment quand on
regarde ce qui se passe en matière de
déforestation dans l'amérique du sud
quand on voit les leçon qu'on peut tirer
en termes de risque de pandémie de cette
déforestation et des liens qui commence
à être établies par certains chercheurs
spécialistes je lis comme vous des
publications des liens commencent à être
est elle établie entre la déforestation
massive et les risques de pandémie
par conséquent il ne nous paraît pas
raisonnable de signer et ratifier un
accord dans lequel des mesures
drastiques ne sont pas prises pour
lutter contre cette déforestation en
amérique du sud
s'agissant du rapport igf ils doivent
être transmis vous parviendra dans les
tout prochains jours mais c'est
effectivement un engagement qui doit
être respectée vis-à-vis du parlement un
dernier mot enfin sur un sujet
important comme tous ceux qui viennent
d'être évoqués mais celui ci a fait
aussi la une de l'actualité de sujets
pardon qui me reste à traiter
carrefour couche-tard et veolia suez sur
carrefour couche tard je vais très
simple avec vous si j'avais à reprendre
cette décision aujourd'hui je prendrai
la même décision parce que l'enjeu
derrière c'est la sécurité alimentaire
des français et je le dis autant qu'au
ministre de l'économie et des finances
que comme ancien ministre de
l'agriculture qui est rompu aux
négociations commerciales entre la
grande distribution et les filières
agricoles françaises la grande
distribution française a bâti un modèle
dont nous devons être fiers et elle a su
inverser au cours des dernières années
une tendance qui était vers
l'approvisionnement en produits qui ne
venaient pas nécessairement de france
qui ne valorisait pas nécessairement la
production française et ils ont compris
et je salue l'orientation qu'ils étaient
prises par toutes les anciennes
française qu'il fallait valoriser les
filières agricoles françaises et avoir
une intégration du champ du chant
jusqu'aux oreilles c'est ce que fait
carrefour des récents porte bien puisque
carrefour ont obtenu de très bons
résultats économiques la semaine
dernière c'est ce que fait le clair
c'est ce que fait intermarché avec des
modèles chaque fois différent en terme
de taille mais je suis attaché à ce
modèle de distribution français qui
valorise la production agricole
française et carrefour vous donner un
seul chiffre représente dans ce système
de distribution française 35% 35% de
l'ensemble des contrats de filières
entre la filière agricole et la grande
distribution française
donc voyez bien que l'enjeu
on peut le prendre comme on le veut est
un enjeu stratégique céder l'intégralité
de carrefour un acteur aussi respectable
soit il que couche tard sans avoir de
garantie que ces 35 % de contrats des
filières agricoles seront renouvelées
que c'est bien ce modèle là qui sera
défendue est un risque que je n'étais
pas prêt à prendre ni hier ni
aujourd'hui en deuxième lieu je me
permettrai juste d'observer que
carrefour est le premier employeur privé
français sans 5000 emplois l'exi magie
de mal le jour où il y a une difficulté
chez wal mart aux états unis je doute
fort que le gouvernement américain
laisserait wal mart se faire racheter
par un acteur étranger où je ne vois pas
pourquoi on pousserait des cris
d'admiration devant la manière dont les
états unis arrivent à défendre leurs
intérêts stratégiques et que nous en
france on ne serait pas capable quand le
premier employeur français est en jeu de
ne pas prendre le même genre de décision
je reprendrai la même décision si elle
était à reprendre enfin sur veolia suez
je vais répéter ce que j'ai déjà dit
dans cette assemblée
quels sont les enjeux il ya un enjeu en
termes dans pour bien entendu et cet
enjeu en termes d'emploi est encore plus
sensible lorsque nous avons une crise
économique de cet emploi il ya un enjeu
auquel vous serez tous sensibles comme
élus locaux en termes de concurrence sur
le marché du traitement de l'eau et du
traitement des déchets et il y a un
enjeu industriel parce que ce sont deux
grands acteurs industriels sur des
activités qui demandent du savoir faire
et les compétences
j'ai toujours indiqué que ce
rapprochement entre veolia et suez
de fait se faire dans un cadre amical je
continue de penser qu une solution
amiable est possible
je continue de penser qu une solution
amiable est à portée de main il faut
simplement que tous les acteurs fassent
preuve de bonne volonté
eh bien je souhaite que dans les jours
et les semaines à venir
les acteurs de ce rapprochement entre
veolia et suez fasse preuve de la bonne
volonté nécessaire pour que ce
rapprochement se fasse de manière
amicale très bien merci monsieur le
ministre je pense qu'il y aura des
réactions parce que j'ai entendu des
réactions au gré de votre intervention
pour des raisons techniques je vais
donner d'abord la parole à jean-marc
boyer parce que je crois qu'il ya des
horaires de train ou je ne sais quoi
donc jean marc et ensuite on prendra
l'ensemble des rapporteurs qui viennent
sur votre votre mission jean-marc donc
bref à la 10ème merci madame la
présidente et merci monsieur le ministre
pour votre optimisme sur le rebond et la
reconquête
la france compte 110 villes thermales
qui pour moi
environ cent mille emplois sont
principalement des villes de 5000
habitants en moyenne donc des petites
villes et le curiste représente 10
emplois
l'activité thermale était touchée de
plein fouet par la crise sanitaire et
subit une inactivité pendant presqu'un
an l'espoir fin 2020 d'une prolongation
d'activité a été anéantie par le
deuxième confinement et les termes
penserait ouvrir début mars avril se
sont préparés qu'un protocole sanitaire
important très strictes en espérant
qu'il n'y a pas un troisième confinement
malgré les mesures emploi partiel p jeux
etc du plan de relance
les chiffres d'affaires sont amputés de
65 à 70%
les six établissements thermaux ont
stoppé les investissements qui était
prévu
quelles mesures de soutien envisagées
vous pour compenser ces pertes non
seulement pour les établissements privés
mais aussi pour les termes gérés en
régie directe et quelles mesures de
soutien pour les communes concernées par
une perte d'activité indirects
considérable merci
jean-marc monsieur le ministre vous
préférez peut-être deux questions à la
fois bon alors on va faire deux
questions à la fois comme south horaire
le temps de préparer la parole est à
serge babary présidente ce sera trois
questions sur j'en ai deux pulls
ministre tout d'abord vous remercier de
ce vaste tour d'horizon sur la situation
économique et sur effectivement espoirs
maintenir deux questions l'une au livre
européen l'autre au niveau local
la commission européenne vient de
décider de prolonger jusqu'au 31
décembre 2021
l'encadrement temporaire des aides
d'état de relever les plafonds dead
halle aux entreprises et permettre la
conversion de certains instruments
remboursables en subventions directes
comment gouvernement envisage-t-il de se
saisir de ces assouplissements
deuxième question sur le plan local de
nos territoires
un nécessaire renforcement de la
décentralisation de l'action publique
doit être envisagée avec le
développement de fonds d'investissement
en fonds propres au niveau local par les
collectivités territoriales
un capitalisme territoriale est une des
réponses à la crise actuelle de nos
territoires qui subissent une des
astuces d industrialisation rampante
quelles mesures envisagées vous afin d'
encourager fiscalement l'orientation de
l'épargné de proximité des français vers
les entreprises dans les territoires
conversi merci serge et on va prendre le
deuxième rapporteur économie franck
montaugé
merci madame la présidente remercie
monsieur le ministre votre présentation
à propos de la stratégie du gouvernement
en matière d'industrie d'avenir que vous
avez évoquées pour prioriser votre
action sur les nouvelles chaînes de
valeur dont vous avez donné quelques
exemples faut-il comprendre que vous
renoncez à relocaliser des filières des
productions à caractère stratégique ou
de souveraineté nationale
on a tous des exemples en tête qui font
mal à l'égo nationale pour ce qui est
des déchaînés de valeurs nouvelles que
vous avez évoqué des indicateurs de
suivi nous permettrait d'évaluer
l'efficacité de l'action du gouvernement
par exemple
si c'est le cas quelle est votre
objectif de part de pipe pour le secteur
industriel à moyen-terme
quels sont vos objectifs correspondant à
l'emploi et quelles conséquences en
tirez vous en matière de formation et de
recherche publique et public privé la
loi à cet égard la loi de programmation
de la recherche que nous avons récemment
votée ne nous rassure pas sur le court
moyen terme en matière justement de
crédit et de moyens consacrés à la
recherche et aux recherches que vous
avez évoquées alors la question est
complexe dans un contexte sous l'effet
de la mondialisation et de l'est et de
segmentation des chaînes de valeur vous
l'avez évoqué le rapport qu'un produit
france stratégie fin 2020 pointe la
fiscalité comme facteur prix money
primordial et presque unique d'un
situation actuelle est ce si simple
autre exemple le projet gaia x a été
annoncée par le gouvernement comme un
élément essentiel de notre souvenir
souveraineté sur les données numériques
un cloud souveraine en quelque sorte et
qui est depuis longtemps espéré mais les
génère géant américain et chinois du
secteur amazon google microsoft alibaba
chinois font partie de l'initiative
or ces entreprises sommes et serons
toujours soumise à des lois de portée
extraterritoriale kieran fragile la
sécurité de l'hébergement des données
sensibles pour les périodes par une
personne physique comme pour les
entreprises
en conséquence cette initiative vous
parait-elle de nature à nous faire
gagner un souveraineté numérique
nationale
je vous remercie merci beaucoup franco
se munissent voulait répondre
ses premières questions
maintenant présidente monsieur boyer son
activité thermal je vous confirme
effectivement que l'impact est
extrêmement lourd
pour toutes ces activités c'est un peu
la double peine c'est à dire qu'à la
fois elle sont formés et en plus
l'activité touristique
cette effondré dans ces îles dont elles
subissent un impact extrêmement lourd de
la crise
je rappelle qu'elles sont éligibles au
dispositif du fonds de solidarité de
l'activité partielle et s'agissant du
fonds de solidarité elles sont éligibles
à l'aide à 200000 euros plafonnée à 200
mille euros représentant 20% du chiffre
d'affaires
je voudrais profiter d'ailleurs de la
question de monsieur boyer pour donner
un état des lieux sur le fonds de
solidarité qui est je le rappelle
aujourd'hui le pilier de la protection
que nous apportons aux entreprises pour
faire face à la crise en particulier les
entreprises fermées du secteur de
l'hôtellerie la restauration et du
tourisme du sport ou de la culture
nous avons ouvert ou 15 janvier dernier
l'ouverture de ce fonds pour le mois de
décembre nous avons reçu 680 mille
demandes à ce jour pour une ouverture au
15 janvier et nous continuons à recevoir
des demandes tous les jours chacun ne
s'inscrit pas dès le 15 ou le 16 janvier
certains s'inscrivent un peu plus tard
nous sommes le 2 février et nous avons à
date 680 mille demandes
au total ça peut aussi inclure des
demandes précédentes qui n'auraient pas
encore été traité mais dans leur immense
majorité ces demandes à partir de
l'ouverture du fonds que 15 janvier pour
le traitement du mois de décembre
il est intéressant de noter que le
niveau moyen de l'aide attribuée au
fonds solidarité a plus que doublé
nous sommes passés de 2400 euros en
moyenne à 5400 euros des dents en
moyenne attribuée par dossier ce qui
montre le
besoins des entreprises et aussi l'effet
du déplafonnement des mesures que nous
avons mises en place qui fait que la
somme moyenne est plus généreuse que
plus du double par rapport au mois
d'octobre
je rappelle également que l'intégralité
des dossiers supérieure à trente mille
euros de demandes font l'objet d'un
contrôle manuel tous les autres et des
filtres automatiques jeu vraiment le
préciser parce que j'ai beaucoup de
questions qui me sont posées par des
entrepreneurs mise à part c'est notre
aide que se passe-t-il d'abord il ya un
montant de demande très élevée près de
700000 et il y à un contrôle qui se fait
dès lors que le dossier représente une
somme supérieure à trente mille euros
trente mille euros par mois ce n'est
évidemment pas une somme non négligeable
est normal qu'il y ait un traitement qui
ne soit pas un traitement automatisé
mais qu'il y ait un contrôle manuel
effectué par les agents la direction
générale des finances publiques
épaulé par les agents de la direction
générale des entreprises
nous avons reçu quatre mille six cents
dossiers pour des demandes supérieures à
30 mille euros au titre des demandes du
15 ans est ouverte au 15 janvier 2006 en
de ces demandes ont été traitées en
quinze jours ou deux mille six cents
dossiers d'entreprises qui demandaient
des sommes supérieures à 30 mille euros
ont été traités en quinze jours avec des
contrôles manuels effectué par la dg fip
et par la dg deux tiers de ces demandes
ont été rejetées et c'est ce dont je
voulais informé le sénat pourquoi tout
simplement parce que dans ces demandes
nous avons noté avec ces contrôles
manuels beaucoup de fraudes au soin des
demandes répétées nous avons beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs
si on demande et pour le même mois
3 sommes différentes avec 3 chiffre
d'affaires de référence différents
nous avons des entrepreneurs qui ont
demandé des sommes importantes alors
qu'il n'y avait aucune déclaration de
chiffre d'affaires dans les années
précédentes
donc tout cela explique je le dis parce
que je vois certaines voix qui s'élèvent
en disant tout cela est trop lent non
nous faisons simplement les choses
sérieusement
nous faisons les choses le plus
rapidement possible avec le souci de
répondre le plus vite possible aux
entrepreneurs qui ont besoin de ce
soutien du fonds de solidarité mais nous
le faisons aussi en veillant à ce que
les fraudes soient les plus limité
possible
ça nous amène effectivement à faire des
contrôles manuels
je le redis sur les 2600 demande une
valeur supérieure à trente mille euros
qui ont été traités en 15 jours les deux
tiers ont été rejetées pour des raisons
j'ai regardé un très grand nombre de
dossiers personnellement pour des
raisons qui sont malheureusement
évidente
c'était hier soir des chiffres
d'affaires de référence qui n'existaient
pas soit des différents chiffres
d'affaires des manants d'une même
personne tout ça nous a amené à rejeter
les demandes mais je le redis nous avons
demandé à des directions générales des
finances publiques de faire le maximum
pour traiter les dossiers le plus
rapidement possible nous voulons porter
l'aide le plus rapidement possible mais
en veillant au bon emploi de l'argent
public
serge babary vous avez raison de noter
que le plafond des aides pour la
commission européenne a été relevé de 3
à 10 millions d'euros
nous utiliserons ce déplafonnement pour
la prise en compte des charges fixes
dans les secteurs qui sont les plus
touchés par la crise nous ferons dont je
le dis très précisément au cas par cas
il peut y avoir par exemple pour les
stations de montagne
je pense aux remontées mécaniques c'est
ce qu'a indiqué le premier ministre il a
quelques jours pour les remontées
mécaniques des stations de montagne les
charges fixant supérieur à 3 millions
d'euros
donc nous utiliserons
pour le secteur de la montagne ce
déplafonnement de l'aide de 3 à 10
millions d'euros
mais je le redis nous le ferons secteur
par secteur
nous étudions aussi la possibilité
d'utiliser ce déplafonnement pour les
grands magasins parisiens par exemple
sur les montants de loyers extrêmement
important et qui sont fermés puisque
nous avons fermé tous les grands
magasins d'une surface supérieure à
vingt mille mètres carrés qui se
retrouve donc avec des loyers
extrêmement élevées en particulier à
part ça a été décidé dans le cadre de la
montagne c'est à l'étude pour les grands
magasins et pour certaines grandes
surfaces commerciales mais je le redis
nous tunisie seront ce déplafonnement de
l'aide que au cas par cas dans des
secteurs très bien définis dans lesquels
en raison leur spécificité le montant
des charges fixes peut être extrêmement
élevé franck montaugé sur la part du
pipe dans l'industrie vous connaissez
tous le tableau clinique je vais pas
revenir dessus
en dix ans la part de l'industrie dans
la richesse nationale a perdu suivant
les analyses six sept ou huit points on
est passé de 18 à un peu moins de 12
al'inverse elle s'est maintenue où elle
a légèrement augmenté en allemagne en
italie
donc il n'ya aucune fatalité la raison
elle tient simplement à des politiques
publiques qui ne répondait pas aux
besoins de l'industrie française dont on
veut prendre le problème par tous les
bouts mais vous avez un problème de
compétitivité prix et vous avez un
problème d'offre
nous avons voulu avec le président de la
république et le premier ministre nous
attaquer à l'ensemble de ces problèmes
qui expliquent la dégradation de la part
de l'industrie dans la richesse
nationale qui est un renoncement
collectif est une faute politique
je les ai déjà dit à plusieurs reprises
ici je le dis là pour le coup autant
comme élu local que comme ministre de
l'économie et des finances la
désindustrialisation fait des ravages
sociaux elle fait des ravages politique
dans notre pays et c'est le fruit d'un
renoncement collectif
dévalorisation de l'industrie d'absence
de réponse aux demandes du secteur
industriel moi je me bats pour
l'industrie et je continuerai à me
battre pour l'industrie parce que
j'estime qu'elle fait partie la culture
française et que renoncer un pan entier
de notre culture c'est une faute
politique autant qu une faute économique
mais si vous voulez garder une industrie
vous pouvez pas avoir des impôts de
production cette fois plus élevée que
votre voisin allemand pardon mais c'est
aussi simple que cela donc on peut
toujours critiquer les décisions du
gouvernement
mais nous nous avons fait le choix
courageux de baisser de 10 milliards
d'euros impôts de production 2021 le 10
milliards d'euros à nouveau en 2022 et
je suis convaincu que c'est
indispensable pour la
réindustrialisation du pays
et ça ne suffira pas il faut en deuxième
lieu une politique d'innovation beaucoup
plus ambitieuse nous avons le crédit
impôt recherche c'est un atout nous
n'irons pas touché le doublement du pays
a dépassé de peu plus de 10 milliards
d'euros à 20 milliards d'euros doit nous
permettre de rattraper notre retard
parce que l'industrie a besoin de
nouvelles technologies de rupture
technologique pour réussir et se
développer en troisième lieu nous avons
besoin de valoriser nos atouts
le nucléaire est un atout pour la france
il est important pour toute une filière
économique
il représente des centaines de milliers
d'emplois ils représentent des
technologies que nous avons mis des
décennies à acquérir et à maîtriser je
le redis le nucléaire est à mes yeux un
atout pour la france
il n'interdit absolument pas de
développer des énergies renouvelables au
contraire et on peut parfaitement
vouloir faire évoluer le mix énergétique
français chercher les nouvelles
technologies de rupture comme hydrogène
développer des énergies renouvelables
comme l'éolien offshore ou de nouveaux
panneaux solaires et dans le même temps
continuer à dire que le nucléaire est un
atout pour la france
je pense que ce n'est absolument pas
contradictoire en tout cas ce sont mes
convictions
en dernier lieu parce que derrière ce
discours il ya un des vrais sujets aussi
de l'industrie française il y a
une question culturelle est ce que oui
ou non nous sommes prêts à valoriser
l'industrie auprès des générations qui
viennent et de leur expliquer que
l'industrie a profondément changé
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez de l'impression
3d avait des logiciels que vous avez
l'intelligence artificielle qui s'opère
dans l'industrie et que par conséquent
l'industrie est un secteur d'avenir
si nous ne disons pas ça aux générations
qui viennent mais nous n'aurons pas les
formations les qualifications et savoir
faire nous avons besoin pour développer
l'industrie de demain
il y a aussi un combat culturel a mené
si nous voulons pour répondre à la
question de franck montaugé inverser la
tendance structurelle depuis 30 ans
depuis 30 ans pour faire remonter la
part de l'industrie notre richesse
nationale ça ne peut être qu'un choix
collectif sera pas le choix du sol mini
de l'économie et des finances ou de
sénateurs aussi respectable soit il qui
sont ici ça ne peut être qu'un vrai
choix collectif est ce que oui ou non
nous voulons redonner à l'industrie ses
lettres de noblesse en france moi je
serai toujours du côté de cette
revalorisation de l'industrie et je
considère que l'équilibré économique
français passe par la revalorisation de
ses métiers industriels
la défense de notre souveraineté
alimentaire et donc de l'agriculture
française et la valorisation des métiers
de service dont je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui ils représentent une part
très importante de notre richesse
nationale
enfin sur le cloud souverain j'aurai
beaucoup plus bref il est important de
pouvoir stocker les données mais soyons
lucides égailler hic c'est un très beau
projet que je soutiens totalement mais
l'entreprise a besoin de stocker ses
données et les valoriser avons-nous
aujourd'hui les moyens d'avoir une
entreprise qui pourra demain valoriser
les données d'une très grande entreprise
française notre prix stratégiques
françaises aujourd'hui il y a un
monopole de quelques grandes entreprises
digital américaine nous enlever citer
quelques unes ou chinoises pense par
exemple à microsoft il sera très
difficile de rattraper ces entreprises
autant je vous dis que sur certaines
nouvelles chaînes de valeur
pour y arriver nous le faisons et nous
allons y arriver autant sur la
valorisation des données je suis
beaucoup plus réservés donc il faut que
nous ayons un système de stockage
s'ouvre à des données dans lequel on
puisse séparer le stockage de la
valorisation
c'est tout l'enjeu c'est ce qui explique
aussi que les débats soient longs et la
recherche soit longue
parce qu'il faut que nous ayons un
accord notamment avec ces gens du
numérique pour qu'ils acceptent que des
données stockées ne soit pas valorisé et
que si elles sont valorisées ils ne
maîtrisent pas la propriété de ces
données jean jacques michau ensuite
eveline renault garabédian merci mais
monsieur le ministre l'ordonance du 23
mars 2020 introduit un certain nombre
d'adaptations une réglementation qui
doit permettre de fait se faire par à
l'épidémie ces deux cas de délégation de
service public d'occupation du domaine
public de budget et plusieurs de ses
dispositions concernent directement les
collectivités
ainsi par exemple dans le cadre d'une
délégation de service public
cette ordonnance suspend les redevances
dues par les entreprises dont l'activité
est fortement dégradée du fait de
l'épidémie
certes l'état prend en compte par ce
biais les difficultés que rencontrent
ces entreprises
en revanche l'impact financier pour les
collectivités et non compensées et
représente un manque à gagner
considérable pour de nombreuses
collectivités dont la situation est déjà
dégradée et dont les redevances servent
à rembourser les emprunts dont monsieur
le ministre quel compensation le
gouvernement peut-il apporter à ces
communes
je vous remercie merci jean jacques et
line renaud garabédian suite civile
merci président monsieur le ministre
souhaiterait vous interroger sur un
aspect particulier de la crise
économique la situation des entreprises
françaises installées à l'étranger
un rapport sénatorial sur la résilience
des entreprises qui a été publié en
décembre dernier établi que plus de 30%
des entreprises installées à l'étranger
ont déposé leur bilan depuis le début de
cette crise ceux dont l'activité se
maintient malgré tous deux bénéficient
d'aucun discours
soutien de l'état français s'agissant
bien entendu d'entreprise le droit local
seuls une dizaine de pays africains
bénéficient via la filiale af des de
besné bénéficient du dispositif de prêts
garantis
pourtant les entreprises françaises qui
sont installés à l'étranger participent
au rayonnement de la france au
rayonnement de notre pays
elle vante le savoir faire français et
commercialise nos produits est ce que
pour sauver et aider ce tissu économique
qui est précieux est ce que nous
pourrions envisager de leur proposer des
solutions adaptées par exemple des prêts
qui pourraient être consentis par le
pays dont les taux d'intérêt seraient
fonction du pays concernés ainsi que de
leurs activités ce serait pour eux bien
entendu un outil précieux pour pouvoir
maintenir leurs activités
est ce que monsieur le ministre que
pensez vous et quel est votre avis cette
situation qui a besoin avant tout d'une
impulsion politique merci merci beaucoup
et flynn sylviane noël merci madame la
présidente monsieur le président on perd
à vous monsieur le ministre harb on se
permet témoin d'associer à mes propos
martin berthès n'a prise à savoir retenu
en séance le tout ce qui c'est fini mais
sans le ski tout est fini cette phrase
résume à elle seule le tsunami vécue par
les territoires de montagne au lendemain
de l'annoncé de la fermeture des
remontées mécaniques de nouvelles
mesures de compensation été annoncée
hier
mais elles ne sont pas encore à la
hauteur de la saison blanche que vous
nous imposez le gouvernement annonçait
que l'intégralité des acteurs de la
montagne serait compensé à hauteur de 70
% des frais fixes
hélas cette indemnisation ne concerne
que les hôtels 4/3 restaurateurs pas les
innombrables autres professionnels qui
subissent les effets collatéraux de
cette fermeture
et pour lesquels l'aide se limitera à
20% de leur chiffre d'affaires seulement
les collectivités locales sont également
très inquiète je souhaite attirer votre
attention sur la situation particulière
des régies autonomes de remontées
mécaniques qui ne peuvent bénéficier du
chômage partiel financées par la
solidarité nationale et vous annoncer
également une compensation intégrale des
pertes supportées par les communes de
montagne dans cette crise là encore vous
ne pouvez pas vous limiter uniquement
redevances des remontées mécaniques et
aux taxes de séjour
qu'en est il des recettes tarifaires
liées aux différents services
directement en lien avec le
fonctionnement des remontées mécaniques
tels que les redevances de parking ou
encore des redevances liées aux
consommations d'eau qui elles mêmes sont
directement liés à la présence de la
population touristique sur nos
territoires pour mercy mercy sylviane
alain chatillon ensuite christian redon
sarrazy oui monsieur le ministre le fond
à ce partenaire marche très bien pour
airbus et l'ensemble de la filière
aéronautique l'utilisation des fonds de
revalorisation sont intéressants
également mais par contre nous
souhaiterions voir si on ne peut pas
alimenter un fond de rebond puisque pour
les fonds de revitalisation et ce sont
des sommes importantes
or il ya aujourd'hui des possibilités
d'acquérir de toutes petites activités à
forte valeur ajoutée qui permettrait de
diversifier ses pme qui sont sous
traitants aujourd'hui l'aéronautique
étant entendu que dans ces tpe il y a
également des entreprises qui travaille
en sous traitance
voilà c'était la suggestion un fond de
rebond et cela se fait paraît-il en
bourgogne
donc vous le savez peut-être aussi bien
aux silos mieux que moi merci beaucoup
merci alain christian roudaut sarrazy
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre je souhaiterais d'abord
abordé le cas particulier des nouvelles
entreprises créées après le 30 septembre
2020 et qui de ce fait ne sont pas
éligibles au fonds solidarité
votre cabinet mais nous l'a confirmé
c'est un trou dans la raquette si je
peux me permettre l'expression qui pose
problème car même si nous n'avons pas
encore de nouveau confinement ces
entreprises doivent faire face à la
crise économique
souvent sans ressources issues de leur
activité ni dette de l'état
la situation étant amenés pour l'heure à
perdurer penser aux mettre en place un
dispositif est un dispositif spécifique
et lequel ma seconde question donc
portera sur un projet de fusion ou de
rachat qui émergent
vous étiez récemment intervenu sur
l'opération carrefour vous avez rappelé
le 22 janvier dans les échos que l'état
avait un rôle de régulation de
l'économie qu'il était là pour définir
les règles économiques et défend
l'intérêt général
comment entendez-vous décliner cette
vision dans vos territoires en
particulier donc sur la situation du
projet de fusion entre société générale
et crédit du nord qui a été confirmée le
7 décembre dernier et qui pourrait
entraîner la disparition de la banque
tarneaud c'est une filiale du crédit du
nord dont le siège social se trouve dans
mon département à limoges ce sont près
de 150 postes qui sont menacés par cette
fusion en particulier les postes
administratifs qui cela a déjà été
avancées pourraient être regroupées pour
le bassin d'emploi de limoges ces
suppressions de postes auraient un effet
dramatique compte tenu du contexte
économique actuel en référence au caveau
déclarations du 22 janvier dans un
dossier comme celui que je viens
d'évoquer aux conséquences fort pour les
territoires de quelle manière l'état
exerce aura-t-il son rôle de régulateur
merci christian michel bonnus ensuite
jean claude tissot merci beaucoup je
suis ministre je une minute je me coupe
je me réserve non ce ministre pour le
pour le pge nous avait dit qu'on
comptait ouvrir le feu que les
restaurants comptait ouvrir le 29
le pge été contractée au mois d'avril
2010 donc sera faire quand on va ouvrir
plus d'un an qu'ils étaient contractés
si on avait su que le pge duré si
longtemps on aurait agi comme aimant
différemment ensuite aujourd'hui le veut
le vrai souci c'est la reprise
c'est qu'est ce qui va se passer après
voilà on a rajouté de la dette à de la
dette donc penser un peu qu'un français
aujourd'hui on lui demande en compte et
pendant un angle et puis après on lui
donne sens à leur vie continue à voir
l'an prochain on peut pas accepter ça
donc moi je veux bien aujourd'hui
emprunter pour deux mois
quitte à rembourser après mais pas pour
ronan la configuration est différente
parce qu'on a ouvert au mois de juin et
on avait le pge et on harper remis au
mois d'octobre
parce que j'ai le pge la can gardez donc
après c'est les aides une fois que notre
une fois que l'entreprise une fac
justement vous avez cité le coup de
sifflet final
omar ouvrir qu'est ce qui va se passer
un événement un congrès un salon un
loisir ça ce pauvre et le tourisme
aujourd'hui va être très impactées à ce
niveau là parce qu'on n'est pas prêt et
parce qu'on ne sera pas suivi
voilà merci michel jean claude tissot
ensuite joël labbé merci madame la
présidente je me dis je vais être très
bref je vais revenir sur le projet recul
récemment le journal du soir a annoncé
plus ou moins le blocage des
négociations entre la commission
européenne et et et vous même
j'aurais simplement savoir vous avez dit
que vous étiez en cours de négociation
avec madame la ministre pompidou metz où
vous en êtes où est-ce qu'on en est
aujourd'hui parce qu'on on entend
presque dire que le projet reculait et
serait mise au garage jusqu'en 2022 donc
où après j'en sais rien voilà c'est ma
question elle est précise et j'ai une
autre question sur les enjeux et
énergétique c'est un secteur clé notre
avantage de notre économie qui doit être
à mon avis considéré avec un peu plus de
je vais pas dire sérieux mais en tout
cas de d'attention et aujourd'hui on le
président de la république a parlé de
guerre quand on quand il parlait de dudu
de la crise du coc vide aujourd'hui on
est presque dans la première si j'ose
dire il est temps de mettre en place un
plan style marshall pour des mesures
peut-être exceptionnel justement pour la
rénovation énergétique
est-ce que vous avez des ambitions
particulières exceptionnel si j'ose dire
parce qu'on connaît les mesures
classiques pour la rénovation
énergétique en particulier
merci monsieur le ministre merci jean
claude joël labbé ensuite jean pierre
moga
merci madame la présidente monsieur
michaud collègues ma question rejoint
celle de claude malhuret tout à l'heure
concernant les commerces de proximité en
plus ri actualité donc vous donner une
réponse limpide sur une règle limpide
50% du chiffre d'affaires
mais il se trouve que beaucoup de ces
commerces de proximité en milieu rural
se trouve en grande difficulté j'en ai
une sur le morbihan à 80 de 7000 euros
de perte de chiffre d'affaires ils ne
vont pas pouvoir s'en sortir alors que
c'est là c'est là le seul commerce du de
ce centre bourg et y en a beaucoup comme
cela en france
est-ce que ce cette règle pourrait être
vue d'une manière ou d'une autre journée
merci joël jean pierre moga
merci merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je voulais vous
interrogé plus longuement sur le pge
mais vous avez répondu à 80 pour sa 2 de
la question que je vous pose est donc je
vais être très bref bon vous le savez
vous êtes conscient ça va être très
compliqué pour certaines entreprises de
résister à la halle à la conjoncture est
notamment membre
vous l'avez souligné pour le les cafés
hôtels restaurants etc alors dans des
cas bien précis et afin de conserver des
secteurs de notre économie qui risque de
disparaître complètement
pourriez vous envisager de transformer
tout ou partie les paies jeu en
subventions merci jean pierre fabre et
ensuite ils jouent
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
une minute une fois par an j'avoue que
c'est court on n'a pas eu le plaisir de
recevoir lors du budget rectificatif les
questions écrites ne trouve jamais de
réponse
bref et comme j'ai une minute et
maintenant quarante secondes ça va pas
invités à la nuance
voilà vous dire juste monsieur le
ministre que j'aimerais beaucoup de
débats avec vous notamment sur ce que
j'ai vu que la crise sanitaire en tout
cas vous n'avez pas ébranlé dans vos
convictions pour rester un libéral de
droite par exemple de vous expliquer je
voudrais avoir un jour le débat et vous
comment vous allez trouver des débouchés
pour les jeunes
si vous proposez comme seul horizon aux
aînés travaillé trois ans de plus j'ai
vraiment une question
moi je partage sur le fait que la
réindustrialisation du pays la
relocalisation et c'est pas exactement
la même chose vous avez raison sur ça va
demander un débat politique exigeant et
vous avez raison mais par exemple est ce
qu on pourrait déjà éviter la casse
sociale qui se déroulent dans le pays et
dans tous les secteurs
moi j'arrête pas de me déplacer les
fonderies du poitou skf renault et air
france bref il faudrait trois auditions
pour faire la liste
donc vous avez aujourd'hui vous refusé
d'interdire les licenciements
vous refusez de conditionner les aides
aux entreprises sur la question sociale
et environnementale
vous refusez même
l'autorisation administrative de la
remettre donc je vous pose une question
comment déjà on évite les drames humains
et la perte des savoir-faire que vous
avez l'air de tenir à bout de bras
comment on fait déjà pour éviter ça et
après se reposera la question comment
industrialise le pays
je vois là je remercie en une minute dix
mais du coup l'année prochaine je me
tairai sûrement pas fabien il vous louez
pour terminer laurent duplomb moitié
d'autres merci mr présidente monsieur
ministres le 27 janvier dernier le
journal marianne s'est fait l'écho des
oubliés du fonds de solidarité
il y à des entrepreneurs qui ont créé un
commerce et ceux qui en ont racheté un
sens historique de chiffre d'affaires
ils n'ont aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui droite à rien tandis que les
charges sont là pour les premiers qui
partent de zéro il serait toutefois
possible de tenir compte du prévisionnel
acceptées par les banques pour lé second
la situation est totalement
incompréhensible
ils ont racheté un fonds de commerce
pourquoi ne pas tenir compte du chiffre
d'affaires du fonds ont racheté je sais
bien sûr votre tâche difficile mais avez
vous prévu d'intégrer ces oubliés du
fonds de solidarité et de leur permettre
l'accès au pge
merci see iv et laurent une minute indre
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre en une minute je vais être le
plus rapide possible
je pourrais vous parler de vos
contradictions l'interdiction du
rapprochement carrefour
couche tard que je veux j'approuve mais
par contre vous avez accepté aldi leader
price
j'aurais pu vous parler de la fermeture
de fessenheim alors vous dites que le
nucléaire est quelque chose d'hyper
intéressant pour la france j'aurais pu
vous parler de l'interdiction des
chaudières gaz que vous allez ainsi thé
avec l'entreprise frisquet qui est bien
française et la problématique des
réseaux de gaz qui ont été tirés dans
toutes nos communes et qui ont coûté la
peau des fesses à la totalité des
communes de france pour refaire les
revêtements et ainsi de suite mais non
je ne vous parlerai pas de ses
contradictions là je vous parlerai
simplement de ce que vous nous avez dit
c'est à dire éviter les faillites en
haute loire
j'ai un souci toutes les entreprises me
disent qu'aujourd'hui les banques leur
demande leur demande de reprendre le
paiement des remboursement d'échéances
qu'il devait faire sur leur ombre elles
ont été repoussées jusqu'à aujourd'hui
et leur demande de les repayer un
restaurateur qui aujourd'hui ne peut pas
ouvrir sans parler des pg e
sans parler des aides quand les banques
leur demande de payer les annuités
qu'ils ont à reprendre c'est les faire
fermer d'office
comment on répond à ces entreprises ça
c'est pas une question d'avenir
c'est une question toute réelle qui se
pose aujourd'hui sur une situation
précise comment répondre à cette
question
si laurent et monsieur munici brest une
rançon pardon que je n'avais pas vu
lever la main voilà qui est là bas
le président rapidement style
télégraphique
quelle est la réflexion sur la
mobilisation de l'épargné des ménages
enfin l'épargné publique qui nageait
motion qui n'a jamais été aussi
importante dans le cadre justement de
l'orientation vers les entreprises et
l'innovation
sachant que en période de sortie de
crise souvent c'est vers l'immobilier
que ces crédits vont aller s'orienter 2
pour le soutien des pme tpe
quelle est la réflexion qui est menée au
niveau du ministère sur le rôle du label
france made in france à l'image de ce
qui a pu se faire dans d'autres pays et
enfin dernier point est ce que les
mesures qui ont été prises pour les
communes de montagne vont être étendus
pour d'autres collectivités je pense en
particulier aux départements qui ont
tant en gestion en particulier des sites
de loisirs ou
des musées qui ont maintenant aussi
j'irai là la fermeture administrative
qui leur empêche d'avoir les recettes et
qui ne sont pas éligibles nico pge ni
aux indemnités
merci monsieur le ministre voilà bien
essayé de ne pas répondre en une seule
minute
j'ai commencé quand même par fabien gay
est ce que fait longtemps effectivement
que nous n'avons pas férié ensemble donc
ça m'a manqué beaucoup je crois que je
reviens au sénat uniquement pour pouvoir
ferrailler avec fabien gay et bien
entendu répondre aux questions de la
commission alors libéral de droite un
grand journal économique disait que
j'étais devenu un interventionniste de
gauche
donc vous vous choisirez moi je ne me
suis jamais défini que comme gaulliste
qui doit être un point d'équilibré entre
le libéral de droite et la cave aux
sionistes de gauche
en tout cas sur la casse sociale je veux
juste indiqué avec beaucoup de fermeté
parce que c'est le travail qui a été
fait par l'état par l'ensemble des
pouvoirs publics et surtout par les
contribuables français
nous avons évité dans toute la mesure du
possible la casse sociale qu réduire
entraîné cette crise économique qui est
la plus lourde que le pays ait eu à
vivre depuis 1929 et je pense que la
grande différence entre la plus grande
crise économique on est connu au 20e
siècle et celle de 1929 et la crise
économique
nous connaissons maintenant c'est que
nous avons retenu une leçon
l'état doit protéger et nous avons
protéger au maximum et nous continuerons
à protéger au maximum les salariés et
les entreprises qui en ont besoin
un choc de cette importance près de 10%
de récession ça ne s'est pas vu depuis
1945 aurait dû se solder par des
centaines et des centaines de milliers
de chômeurs supplémentaires
oui il y a eu du chômage supplémentaires
et croyez moi on a conscience de la
gravité que ça peut représenter pour
tous ceux qui sont touchés pour tous
ceux qui sont en situation précaire pour
tous ceux qui n'ont pas les
qualifications pour pouvoir rebondir
facilement mais nous avons
marty le choc sur l'emploi ça aurait dû
se solder par un tsunami de faillite il
y en a eu moins en 2020 qu'en 2019 ça
aurait dû mettre par terre et vous le
savez parfaitement mais ce gain ça
aurait dû mettre par terre un certain
nombre de très grandes entreprises comme
air france comme renault nous leur avons
apporté 7 milliards d'euros de soutien
pour air france 5 milliards d'euros de
soutien pour renault et je pourrais
multiplier les exemples
l'entreprise que nous avons soutenu et
en les soutenant nous avons évité la
classe sociale on peut toujours faire
mieux mais je considère et c'est
l'évaluation qui est fait aussi bien par
le fonds monétaire international que par
l' ocde que par l'ordre des greffiers
des tribunaux de commerce que par les
experts comptables que l'état a été au
rendez vous dans sa réponse économique à
la crise
on peut toujours faire mieux mais je
pense que le travail qui a été fait par
les fonctionnaires des ministères de
l'économie et des finances et les choix
politiques qui ont été faits par le
président de la république et par le
premier ministre mérite en la matière en
tout cas c'est mon avis d'être salué
s'agissant la mobilisation de l'épargné
des ménages questions de laurent au
saumon c'est une question absolument
majeur puisque je rappelle que c'est
l'équivalent de ce que nous mettons sur
la table avec le plan de relance
donc nous avons mis en place un label
relance pour flécher dépeint des
français à des produits d'investissement
favorable au soutien des entreprises
françaises nous allons développer ce
label pour nous assurer qu effectivement
les pagnes des français aille bien vers
les entreprises françaises en matière
d'investissement et par ailleurs ce que
je constate c'est qu'en matière de
consommation et donc de relance par la
demande lorsque les règles sanitaires
sont levés la consommation est au rendez
vous et il a aussi tout simplement parce
qu'on à préserver le pouvoir d'achat des
français
- on
pour cent de récession moins 8,3
finalement et une quasi stabilité du
pouvoir d'achat des ménages même si j'ai
parfaitement conscience que ça casse des
situations extraordinairement diverses
extraordinairement diverses formes
moyenne le pouvoir d'achat des classes
moyennes françaises a été protégé par
notre réponse vous m'avez interrogé sur
l'étalement des presses entreprises
risquaient également
je vous tiens simplement vous dire que
j'ai reçu le président de l'entreprise
de frisquet et non mais je suis bien
quelque chose sur les chaudières à gaz
derrière mais c'est eux il me semble que
vous avez posé une question aussi centre
pris ce risque et pardon je crois vous
en doutez vous interroger sur
l'entreprise frisquet dont j'essaie
juste de répondre aux questions qui
m'ont été posées
enfin nous verrons nous verrons dans le
compte rendu de la séance si vous avez
bien posé une question sur les
chaudières à gaz et sur l'entreprise
risque et je crois que c'est le cas donc
j'ai reçu le président d'entreprise
frisquet qui d'une magnifique entreprise
installée en seine-et-marne qui
représente près de 800 emplois ma
connaissance dans le département de la
seine et marne et nous sommes en train
d'étudier ce qui peut être fait pour
soutenir une entreprise qui se
diversifient justement sur d'autres
modes de production et qui a
parfaitement raison de le faire
s'agissant des prés du remboursement des
échéances nous avons demandé la
fédération bancaire française que je
reverrai à nouveau deux choses d'une
part a différé de paiement pour le
remboursement du capital des prêts
garantis par l'état de 1 à 2 ans et pour
les prêts précédent nous avons demandé
d'étudier au cas par cas une possibilité
de délais supplémentaires pour les
entreprises qui en auraient besoin et se
sont engagés à le faire et donc nous
avons un médiateur du crédit qui est là
pour veiller à ce que à chaque fois
qu'il ya une demande et traitées
correctement sont les oubliés du fonds
de solidarité pas été moi juste de
renverser un tout petit peu la question
je veux pas valoriser tout ce qui fait
par la direction générale des finances
publiques mais je rappelle que lorsque
nous avons ouvert
lisibilité au fonds solidarité le 15
janvier c'est plus cent mille dossiers
qui sont arrivés à la direction générale
des finances publiques le premier jour
cent mille le lendemain donc je pense
avoir une couverture aujourd'hui qui est
extrêmement large
il peut y avoir encore des failles dans
le dispositif nous les complétant je
demandé au directeur général des
finances publiques
jérôme fournel de faire le nécessaire
nous avons bien noté effectivement la
demande qui a été formulée sur ce sujet
mais je le redis
l'essentiel aujourd'hui est couvert et
s'il ya des failles d'un nous veillons à
les combler systématiquement sa
transformation des pg en subventions
soyons très prudent moi je vais utiliser
toutes les facultés qui sont offertes
par la commission européenne en matière
de prêts garantis par l'état
enfin je rappelle que ces prêts comme
leurs noms l'indiquent sont garanties
par l'état
donc lorsqu'il ya un défaut sur le prêt
c'est l'état donc le contribuable qui
paye donc ça ne peut être qu'une
solution de toute maniére cours sous
forme de dettes que pourra apporter
l'état dans les situations vraiment
critique où cela pourrait être justifié
nous garderons cette ligne kessel la
protection maximale de l'économie
française mais ne saisit pas non plus
d'exposer abusivement nos finances
publiques et le contribuable sur la
pluriactivité jouer de l'abbé je pense
que c'est une bonne idée non pas de
revoir les critères mais le faire preuve
de souplesse dans l'interprétation des
critères si dans le cas du commerce que
vous avez indiqué je sais à quel point
je le vois dans mon département de
l'eure et dans la circonscription alors
sur une commune rurale et qui a un seul
commerce il faut tout faire pour le
sauver ça c'est absolument évident mais
si on est à 46 54 au lieu d'être à 50 50
il faut regarder si on ne peut pas
inclure l'entreprise dont le bénéfice du
fonds de solidarité
donc si vous avez une part fermé qui est
légèrement inférieur à 50% ça ne pose
pas de difficulté de faire preuve de
souplesse dans l'interprétation si ça
permet de sauver un commerce de
proximité dans une commune rurale
ça me paraît parfaitement légitime
sur la rénovation énergétique et les
montants qui sont mis je rappelle juste
les chiffres on est sûr de mémoire 6,4
milliards d'euros qui sont accordées à
la rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
dont quand on ne parle de plan marshall
on est vraiment sur un plan marshall est
un dispositif absolument massif de
soutien à la rénovation énergétique et
des bâtiments publics et des bâtiments
privés avec ma prime raynaud je crois
qu'on fait vraiment l'essentiel pour que
les choses avancent vite
vous m'avez aussi interroger mais ce
tissot sur le blocage des négociations
la commission européenne il n'y a pas de
blocage des négociations sur edf
je poursuis mes discussions avec madame
resta guerre à raison de un ou deux
appels par semaine sur ce sujet et sur
d'autres sujets que nous avons un traité
actuellement avec elle c'est une
négociation qui est difficile chacun le
sait parce que les enjeux sont
importants mais nous avons une qualité
de relations excellentes avec madame
vesta guerre qui doit nous permettre sur
les différents sujets de progresser
l'épée je crois avoir répondu sur
question très importante sur les
entreprises qui sont créés après le 30
septembre 2020 nous voulions simplement
à ce qu'il y ait un délai de deux mois
entre la date de création de
l'entreprise et lisibilité au fonds de
solidarité pour éviter tout simplement
les effets d'aubaine c'est à
l'entreprise qui ne seraient créés que
pour avoir accès aux fonds de solidarité
donc la date est systématiquement
décalée d'un mois lorsque les deux mois
sont passés donc pour l'instant les 30
septembre 2020 qu'on arrivera ensuite au
30 octobre 2020 et aux mesures que le
fond célérité est maintenu nous décalons
la date d lisibilité en veillant à
garder ses deux mois de délai pour
éviter les effets d'aubaine
alain chatillon sur
ah c'est aux partenaires c'est
effectivement un fonds qui marche très
bien pour soutenir l'investissement dans
l'aéronautique
l'idée d'un fond de rebond peut
parfaitement la fin de rebond
complémentaires parfaitement être
étudiée j'ai surtout indiqué qu'il
faudrait veiller à prolonger la durée
des dispositifs pour l'aéronautique
parce que nous sommes dans une crise qui
s'installe dans la durée et que la durée
de deux ans qui avait été prévu
initialement et sans doute trop courte
il faudra donc la prolonger s'il vient
de noël sur les stations de ski
je rappelle qu'elle dispose d'un
dispositif désormais totalement
dérogatoire qui est parfaitement
légitime au regard de la difficulté de
la situation qui est la leur de cette
saison blanche qui leur est imposée pour
des raisons sanitaires
mais nous avons veillé à ce que
l'intégralité des commerces et stations
de ski le montant souhaité lisible au
fonds de solidarité à 20% du chiffre
d'affaires ce qui n'est pas le cas je le
rappel de tous les commerces mais
seulement normalement des commerces
fermés ou des commerces associés aux
commerces fermés
nous avons également veiller à ce que
les remontées mécaniques sont éligibles
au remboursement des frais fixes tels
que définis par la commission européenne
c'est-à-dire au-delà des 3 millions
d'euros donc on a un nouveau plafond à
10 millions d'euros qui permet de
répondre aux attentes
donc nous avons des mesures de
compensation qui sont massives et qui je
l'espère répondront aux attentes des
professionnels en aussi combler
certaines failles notamment sur les
indépendants sur les moniteurs de ski et
j'ai bien pris note de ce que m'avait
dit c'est la régie autonome des
remontées mécaniques et chômage partiel
sur lequel je transmettrai la question à
elisabeth bornes sur les entreprises
françaises à l'étranger faites moi part
de vos propositions
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui l'essentiel de
nos mesures vont évidemment entreprises
qui sont installés en france pour
protéger l'emploi en france mais je suis
ouvert à toute proposition dans ce
domaine là enfin jean jacques michau sur
les collectivités locales rappelle
nous avons porté 4,4 milliards d'euros
de soutien aux collectivités locales
pour compenser les pertes de recettes
2020 2021 et soutenir également les
autorités locales en matière de mobilité
je pense au stif en ile de france bien
entendu nous avons emporté 2 0 6
milliard d'euros de soutien à
l'investissement avec la des cils la
dotation région et la rénovation
thermique donc déjà indiqué et nous
avons également 3 milliards d'euros de
mesures de relance qui sont destinées
exclusivement aux collectivités locales
voilà je ne suis pas plus long que je
dois au coût de thé mais je vous
remercie de la qualité de nos entretiens
comme toujours
[Musique]